اخفاق امني ضخم اذا يخفي خلفه اخفاقا اخر
وكافحه التغيير والتغيير اجل ما يخيف
الانظمه الشموليه ويهدد وجودها وهنا ايران
خسرت حربها الثقافيه
خذي بقى المرشد الثقافيه كما اسمه تسرب
الى داخل اسوار المجتمع المنغلق قصرا
بتوجيهاته والانترنت عدوه الاول حجمه لم
ينفع برامج البي بي ان افك الحظر والتشفير
تباع في البقاله بحسب النائب الايراني
ذبيح الله اعظمي
ومن البقاله يفتح فضاء التهديدات على
بوابه الحرب الناعمه التي حذر المرشد من
تدميرها لايران محاربتها تستوجب التاثير
على الايرانيين بدءا من عقولهم وهنا تاكيد
اخر على ان حل شرطه الاخلاق لم يكن سوى
اجراء شكليا في منظومه تمثل فيها دور ضابط
ايقاع ايقاع البسيج التي اكلت اليها مهمه
التركيز على التهديدات الثقافيه
20 الف رجل دين اعين في 250 الف دائره
مهمتهم التدريب الديني في رياض الاطفال
الى الجامعات وهكذا يتفاخر محمد رضا نقدي
القائد السابق للبسيج تعليمات هؤلاء تسير
بالتوازي مع خطه التحول الديموغرافي احلال
من يتعارض فكريا وقوميا مع النظام في
شريحه المفضله له الفارسيه بالضروره يشجع
النظام ابنائه واحفاده على الانجاب وليس
بالمعدل الطبيعي الذي فرضه منذ ثمانينات
محددا متوسط الطفلين لكل عائله القاده
العسكريون يشجعون عضوات الحرس الثوري على
انجاب خمسه اطفال على الاقل للحصول على
مكافات تقاعد مبكر اسهم المجانين في
المؤسسات الوطنيه وخمسه الاف دولار في شكل
قرود بعد انجاب الطفل الثالث